the original star Daniel Gillies stopped
by ET studios to open up about his wife
of 12 years she's all that star Rachel
Leigh Cook and if they're ready for
another baby
do you ever just like look at her and be
like I can't believe I ended up with
Laney Boggs well this is gonna sound
like the creepiest thing of all time but
like I I do look at her sometimes and I
can't believe how how beautiful she is
the when I was first married to that
this is the creepy thing I'll say who
cares I said I remember like her
sleeping next to me in just being asleep
because I mean that's about to make a
terrible joke there
um I won't do it but but I remember just
watching a same thing that is the most
beautiful person and I just watch her
for a while it's also amazing to see
when our kids have inherited some for
her physical characteristics you're like
well cuz you're getting to start to see
that they have little personality
Charlotte you said it's three and a half
Maryna theaters two he just just turned
two but what does it been like to see
their dynamics together because now like
Charlotte's fully aware that like
theater is here to stay yeah but she is
a very sweet over sister to him and
she's day-by-day becoming sort of more
and more like that's almost like
demonstrative Leigh like she'll be
really sweet to my son okay look daddy
look how great I mean like so that she
can receive the reward later on which is
inevitably that I have to play her
episodes of Dora the Explorer you're not
a parent you'll get to know door trust
me
do you feel like you guys might want to
have another child no you're gonna
outnumber you Oh daddy's gonna you're
gonna pay a special visit to a special
surgeon real soon that's not that's not
get no because I mean I'm too old as it
is my wife has gotten gonna be energy of
the 21 year old and it's physically in
great condition me I mother like have no
knees in those shoulders I I can't no
it's the answer that I want to be able
to give these to my love and attention
and care I would like to stop now